oh it's nice place yeah crazy how empty
it is for a Tuesday afternoon though
what can I get you gentlemen Hey we will
have two beers oh no no no we only serve
wine yeah what am i my parents I've
never had wine before wow I have tasted
the forbidden fruit with some sort of
child sacrifice for this what year was
this bottled I won't drink anything
younger than 1800 I want seven pounds of
a cheese plant you can really taste the
notes of chocolate I'm picking up hints
of rocky road maybe it's because we
visited an ice cream parlor beforehand
look at me I'm a wino Souris get that
this wine has a great set of legs like
our model friend Heidi Klum that's good
oh what a fantastic song young bro
we'll have I love sorry no wrong I am so
funny when I drink wine I should be on
David Letterman you're funnier than my
court jester oh good I was just drinking
some gossip juice loose lips sink ships
and I'm the captain of the Titanic did I
tell you my son Preston got spending
from Academy and get him for saying the
word sexy too much in class did you hear
that Brenda's husband got kicked out of
the country club cuz he only took the
caddy $50 again Oh looks like I'm about
to send an email to my ex what TC what
do you mean you want to meet tonight
look at me up crying porpoise does
anyone have a hundred dollar bill to
blow my nose I am NOT an alcoholic if
it's wine wine is good for you we're
never going to die
alright buddy my hair back
[Music]